欢迎收听赵华语古获载第1124集
今天是2026年的6月23号
今天的台股终于跌了
但也没有非常奇怪
因为昨天的台股说实话
涨到这个1300 1400多点的时候
有那么一点超涨的味道
今天有点把超涨的部分给跌回来
不过因为如果大家手上比较多是中小型骨的话
今天的体感温度就相对比较烂一点
尤其今天盘面上的族群性
几乎只剩下功率元件跟部分的细光子
像大家耳熟难详
可能手上也买了不少的被动元件
今天是有点团灭的味道
光学细晶圆也在跌
今天的大牛股大概还是联电表现的最好
昨天晚上的ADR联电是涨了14个百分点
但今天也因为盘式的关系
它就受到了一点压抑
而且因为台积电演了大半场的这个撑盘要角
最后杀尾盘
所以中场我们下跌了640点
感觉640点还好
不过这个640点有带量
今天的量在上市的部分有放大到1.6兆
而上位的部分是3000多亿
加起来是快2兆的量
在今天是个下跌盘
那下跌加速是远远高于上涨加速
所以今天的体感严格来说不好
不过呢今天的来宾
他看到我的第一句话是说
有跌吗 跌的没有很多
因为我们两个其实都知道
如果下跌是要给机会
我們的信念真的是如此
今天有影片版
所以我先不囉嗦
我先歡迎他出場
免得在影片上看到他被晾在旁邊
今天來的是AI達人蔡明翰
趙華 觀眾朋友聽眾朋友大家好
因為剛剛我一看到明翰
我就說你今天來的時機很好
因為明翰不喜歡在大漲的時候來
大漲的時候比較不好講
然後他喜歡在大跌的時候來
但今天又跌的不夠多
不過我有提到
今天中小星過的T感比較差
因為跪滿跌了
快要三個百分點
那因為台積電跌一咪咪
所以相較之下
你就可以理解
我可能你手上的股票
很多是今天就忽然跌個五六%
再加上因為昨天
我有跟這個明翰講
我覺得昨天是一個
很奇妙的氣氛
昨天我有聽到
非常多的人跳進去買股票
所以今天雖然跌的不算很多
甚至連認真回檔
可能都還不算
可是可能有一些人的感受
已經變得很不好就是有一點點追在比較高位階的關係所以這邊對明海來說我們要講的一件事情是依舊是看好不變因為我們有提到現階段眼前
已經沒有什麼特別大的利空了
就算美衣好像還沒有真的喬好
你會發現市場很淡啦
因為油價沒有上來嘛
那展望到7月
甚至會有陸續的好消息
所以今天的回檔
你會覺得就要趕快買呢
還是要有什麼警覺呢
因為今天是帶量的下跌
我覺得帶量下跌這個東西
其實我在節目也拆解過很多次
就是說高檔帶量下跌
如果回到這個23年AI以前
確實就代表著可能即將反轉
但是從23年以後
我們給大家過很多次的證據
每次高檔爆量黑K棒
本來都是主力逃跑的訊號
但是這個真的是遮起來
跟你講說過往都這樣
那後來真的每一次都不超過三天
它又創高
所以高檔黑K棒爆量
其實現在都不能從技術面角度去拆解
我每一次都說
現在的基本面
應該說是歷史最強性的時間點
所以常常講
應該說基本面掛帥的情況下
你在這個技術面跟籌碼面
真的稍微看輕一點
你不要把這個技術面看得太重
不然會導致很大的現象
比如說現在高檔爆量就要跑
跑了之後不到三天它又創高
你又得追回來
所以技術面的部分
我這樣看輕一點就好
基本面確實是比較重要的關鍵點
那剛剛也提到
就是說這段時間能夠有雜音的
不外乎就是兩個
一個就是戰火的部分
另外一個就是聯準會
是只有這兩個
可是我剛剛講
真的今年不要花時間
再關注這兩個東西
被你講這種一件事
就是明漢上次有講說
以後再聽到什麼
因為升息啊
什麼造成的動亂
那就是買
結果聯準會的會議之後
其實市場的反應是
不管你講的是不是因
我就覺得事情過了
對 應該說那個壓力很小
因為這一次比較特別就是
大家本來在等降息
我就跟你講 你也不用等降
因為沒有降息根本不會怎麼樣
對不對 那問題
我那時候講
如果升息就不一樣了但是這一次大家一講到升息大家就很害怕可是我刚才讲说要记得一个架构升息不是只有这两个要升息他到底是升息是为了应付某些事情
还是未来是一个升息的趋势
那故事是不一样
那你可以看到说
就算二六年
今年就算有机会升息
我个人觉得有没有机会升息
其实就现在角度
几率还很低
因为油价不断往下走
所以照理讲
其实也没有必要
一定要升息
好 我們就算要升息好了
最多也是升息一碼
好 那應該這樣講
假設今年升息一碼
後面會怎麼看
一定是往下走了
就是最多往後看
不管是今年明年
升息最多也是一次
中長線的趨勢一定是往下
所以這一次到底有升或沒有升
老實講並沒有意義
應該說這是一個趨勢
或者是我們簡單角度來講
就是說最近假設
AI的動能假設出現了某些問題
那你就要去了解
到底是趋势到頂了
還是說短線的雜音
就像我們之前講的
搞不好這個AI在
揮達的今天在轉換的時候
搞不好有可能會delay
一delay就會導致
台灣的部分可能營收稍微減弱
可是如果今天是趋势反轉
那當然是恐怖
問題是如果是短線delay來講
其實後續都還是會走高
所以反向而言都是加碼機會
所以其實在聯準會的部分
我個人覺得
結論就是我真的覺得
不需要花太多時間
這是我的工作
所以我必須要把大家拆解得很詳細
告訴大家說這個不重要
這個重要不重要
如果今天要是我真的已經退休
我根本不需要幫大家拆解
老實講我自己對我投資來講
我連主婚我連看都不想看
因為我覺得那根本
真的一點都不重要
戰火也一點都不重要
因為無論它再怎麼翻桌怎樣
最嚴重就是在三月
就是已經過了
那後面我常常講
利空比的不是
真的不是次數
不是說我今天又講了幾次壞消息
這是幾次不重要
你只要沒有比第一次大
後面的利空其實都沒有意義
所以結論來講
現在看起來沒有太大的利空
那回歸基本面
今年能夠漲降其實都是基本面
那這個每一季的
無論是美股的財報或台股的法說會
其實都是正向的
那所以就目前的角度看起來
在這一季應該都還有機會延續
所以我個人覺得趨勢來講還是在往上不要被這個所謂的今天這樣稍微壓回就有點恐慌或者是我結論來講我們反過頭來
今天在跌什麼
其實很簡單 兩個道理而已
第一就是這個昨天漲太多
這個我覺得這還其次
第二很重要就是覺得
我個人覺得市場已經預期
美股斜率太陡
代表今天晚上
美股必须得修正
还是回到乖离率跟协率
应该这样讲
台股今天赌的就是
美股今天晚上会修正
所以会导致一个现象
明天会长什么样的台股
其实就很容易推论
如果今天晚上美股
跟假设像今天的台股一样小跌
那就会导致明天台股不跌
甚至还有可能慢慢的往上
那如果今天晚上猜错了
就还在继续往上
我講的是廢半 假設廢半繼續往上
台階AD還在往上 那不好意思
那明天就得補漲
那等於所以結論而言
就今天的角度 趨勢反轉了嗎
技術面怎樣 我老這樣
我覺得根本就不是很重要
因為趨勢利空其實都逐漸消失
那利空消失利多
應該說即將都是看到正向的
所以現在拉回
不要用一天的這個走勢下去做解讀
我覺得很有趣
因為我知道大家都很期待明翰來
但是今天的盤啊
雖然感覺上是體感很差對不對
可是我必須說
對我和明翰來說
他有點偏無聊
就是他有點
只能跟大家先講一下發生什麼事
像第一點就是
我覺得沒有發生什麼樣真正的利空
而就是昨天有點操長
所以今天有點吐回來
跟明翰講的一樣
假設今天晚上美股突然變得很強勁
那不好意思明天就要補回來
今天有點在補昨天的
還有就是最近啊
期貨的正價差真的很猛耶
因為到了快7月了
歷年幾乎都是有一個比較明顯
可能五六百點的逆價差
哇 昨天晚上夜盤的正價差
已經拉到一千多點耶
這是怎樣
我昨天看了夜盤我就想說
四萬九千多
四萬九千多的夜盤
你再漲一下下
感覺明後天就要五萬點了
我是以台紙期來說
但我昨天還很想跟人家打賭說
你覺得這個月底錢會不會五萬點
後來都沒人要跟我賭
我現在聲名狼藉
因為之前贏了人家太多次
但重點就是
在今天一開盤的時候
你就可以感受到
這個夜盤的樂觀
在一夕之間
你今天是要稍微做一點回土的
那今天還有一個
蠻有趣的現象
今天的期貨空單
一口氣增加了6000多口
所以現在大概是
75000、76000多口的空單
這也是我們沒看過的
但因為我們有明顯的增加差
所以套利的成分是在的
我把今天的過程跟大家交代一下
但今天說實話沒事
我們呼應一下
明漢講的華許的這個關過了之後
然後美伊
其實你打油價也沒起來之後
這兩件事情
顯然就不是市場上關心的
所以接下來我們就會回到繼續看基本面
那當然現在可能有點空窗期
因為台藝店還沒開法說
也還沒有新的營收
那這個禮拜還會公布警器堆測訊號
應該也是個紅燈
所以就是一個樂騰騰的狀況
而且我有跟明漢討論
其實現在講六月底只剩一個禮拜了
講到七月還蠻多好消息值得期待的
對應該我們剛剛提到
基本面的角度出發其實
因為畢竟是一季季節
所以代表到6月底才算是完整的季度
所以7月開始到7月中
就會有台積電的法說
那應該是最前面的領先指標
那延續應該說從有AI以來
一直都是很樂觀
那我常常講
它的特色就是股價其實都長在前面跟後面
真正法說會其實是不會長的
不管講再好都沒有用
這個就是每一次的特性
那這個就是逆著人心
因為現在市場是不會講的
但是他就是常常在
大家不會去提到的時候
他就一直偷偷的這個不斷的走高
然後走到這個
可能法說會前一兩週
大家開始把這個目光
移到這個台積電每天來講說
外資已經出去報告
認為下禮拜的法說會
這次市場最熱的時候
其實他就已經不漲
這每一次的特性
所以我也認同
因為投資本來就是有點心理學
就是心理戰
大家你本來就應該在
這個市場不熱的時候先進去
然後等到熱的時候
大家就會開始
前面卡的人就會開始退場
那所以就基本面而言
確實還是維持一個比較樂觀的一個態勢
所以有機會持續的這個推升
這個所謂的股價不斷走高
尤其剛剛提到
我一直認為出口數字是一個非常重要的關鍵
因為之前有時候
常常人家問我說
这个到底台股现在长成这样来到四万点到底会不会泡沫我常常讲的你会认为泡沫原因的最大的问题
就是看新闻
因为新闻有一个
比较麻烦的问题
就是新闻它都是
所谓的字面的讯息
所以你完全看不到图形长相
到底长什么样子
那我常常讲
你会担心台股是不是泡沫
原因就是因为你不知道
台灣現在到底有多厲害
因為為什麼
原因很簡單
因為這個是台灣M型化很大的原因
因為你要知道台灣現在
你要出口是在創歷史新高
這是你要知道幾十年來
台灣現在是在最強悍的時候
而且有一個
我覺得為什麼台灣投資人會相對而言
這要怎麼說
就是會一直很擔憂
我覺得是可以理解的
因為我剛剛講的最重要的問題
就是M型化
就是说从基本面的角度出发
从台湾应该说
所有的上班族而言
你真正感受到说
你从上班
从公司的角度发现说
现在好到不得了的人
其实是少数的
就只有AI那几家公司而已
没错吧
那你其他人
你每天去上班
你会觉得
你自己在生活上的体感
跟股市上的体感截然不同
你会觉得股市怎么那么热
可是每天我的生活间就感受不到经济有这么好
可是那个是因为现在M型化很严重
真的我常常讲台湾的出口数字是创高的
可是主技术所有的统计产业真的全部都是平的
只有两个就一个是电子零组件
一个是自通讯产品不断的用喷出的
所以这些公司毕竟是少数的
所以只有这些人有体感
而且他應該說他們有他們的優勢
第一 他自己知道現在狀況很好
也許他就會 無論是他自家公司
或者是上下游的公司 他會去做投資
加上還有一個問題 因為公司獲利很好
所以他不只可能一般的薪水很好
重點是獎金給的真的是很多
隨便他們給個獎金
都是一般上班族好幾年的年薪
那所以雙重效應
人家可以賺大錢
但一般投資人就會一直很緊張因為自己在生活間總覺得還好而已但是股市不斷的衝出去我常常講 你會擔心泡沫原因就是因為你不知道現在台灣到底有多厲害
全球都在看台灣的臉色
這也是不真的事實
那我常常講就是說
長期而言 從最早的AI是
軟體公司的那個時候
他們說話比較大聲
這一段時間在高速成長
就變成是硬體
當然最終一定是回到軟體
說話為主
但是現在剛好在第二階段
就是所謂的硬體的時間點
所以台廠剛好就吃到這幾年的紅利
那目前的角度
無論是季節性因素
應該說如果從今年的角度來講
下半年才是旺季的時間點
那如果對比26 27 27也還在持續走高
所以如果從季度或年度的角度
都可以確認現在不是高點
當然很多人會講到
這個股價漲這麼多了
是不是這些利多都已經反映在裡面了
所以他會擔心是不是泡沫
我常常講就是說
這個股市就是反映半年 就是兩季
那你如果現在是已經是年中了
所以如果你的這個公司成長只有今年
那你現在真的應該要下車
因為明年不確定的公司
然後今年漲很多的
你可能就要小心
但是如果像AI族群
大家對明年的看法都還那麼樂觀
他只要真的很純的AI股
其實現在就算本益比偏高
那是因為漲太多用今年的獲利
那等到下半年用明年的獲利
又覺得相對來又不高
所以代表著中間休息
都是一個很好的機會
所以我要重申
就是說從基本面的角度
其實M型化也是蠻重的
那漲多自然這個拉回的過程當中
相對而言大家都會拉回
但我還是覺得
投資人盡量選擇比較有數字的族群
那相對而言後續來講
等待指數只要一穩住
他們的股價都還是會相對比較強勢
其實我們討論了很多
就是關於我們現在台灣產業
不管是說M型化也好
或是所謂的K型化也好
對不對
就是有一部分是一直往下的
然後跟AI相關的就一直往上
這個裂口會越來越大
就像有人問我說
他說你們電視台啊
應該這兩年的業績也很好
我說No
因為電視台是社會的縮影就電視台其實它收到的例如說那種你們看到的那種秒數廣告就是播了很多那種廣告影片的那種中間它是來自消費性的商品
其實消費性的商品沒有特別好
那你說那些AI公司
它很多是B2B
就是商業型的
它很少B2C的
它可能也沒有投廣告
到我們這種所謂的電視台
所以我們也算是有點小艱困
可是如果你有去投資AI相關領域
你有做理財的人
你可能感受又不一樣
就算你所处的产业
它并不是在这两年成长
甚至还受到了一点挑战跟压力
可是你的资产却是可以持续往上的
我觉得这个是这几年
大家在资产的翻转上面
很重要的一个观念
那也会有人
刚才现在就来这个致命题好了
都已经涨到47000
接近48000了
如果我现在才要进来投资的话
那我要怎么样确认
我不是买在最高点
确认是不是买在最高点
我是帮一般人
还没有进来的人问
应该这样讲
我刚刚讲一个很重要的观念
你现在要进场
你不要再去管
现在发生什么事情
你第一件事情
只有一个中心思想
你到底认不认同
27年比现在更好
我觉得这才是最重要的关键
你现在短时间发生什么事情
什么战争
什么那些滑雪都已经不重要
因为我刚刚讲
股市会反映半年之后的事情
所以就我刚刚讲
就算今年下半年升息一马
又怎么样
因为你要的是27年的趋势
他们点正图2728是持续往下的
所以就算今年下半年升级一码
不重要
因为你要的
现在结论都是在反映27年的架构
那我就讲了
你中心最中心的思想
你要回过头来
你到底认不认同27年的AI
还是一股很强的一个热潮
那就目前的角度
我会觉得
你不管从专业
各公司
到底有谁
对27年的AI看法是保守的
目前真的找不到任何的
这个人说法是保守
当然有时候人家会讲
那些人就是他们家在卖东西的
当然是乐观
包含黄仁勋
他家在卖晶片
他怎么可能告诉你不好
但事实好不好
我常讲的这些公司
尤其我们最后我常讲
台积电说的话总能信了吧
他就告诉你
到底行不行
他的法術會都直接告訴你
到2029年
他們看營收能夠維持增長25%
那我會覺得
他们当然我觉得他敢放这个话
就真的才有勇气
因为他可以一次看到
未来的这个三年的远景
我会觉得说没关系
你就算三年你觉得讲得有点太远
那也无所谓
最基本来讲到明年
其实应该都不会有太大的趋势改变
那或者是应该这样很大的问题
就现在的角度
AI使用率其实我还是觉得
就今年的角度
应该说现在已经年中了
我们再回到去年底
经过半年
我个人觉得
AI的使用率的攀升
我自己的感受
我觉得是有点不如预期的
就是我还是觉得
会用的就是永远都在用
不会用的
你怎么跟他讲
他也不会用
有啦 有渗透率加高吧
我觉得有加高
但是那个幅度远不及想象
因为我个人觉得
现在AI
尤其这半年来
AI的成长跟好用的攀升度是非常高的
就是我们现在用的AI跟半年前的AI
是落差非常非常大
但是市场使用的渗透率的攀升
比想象的慢很多
所以代表当然这个算是利空吗
但我个人觉得不是代表现在就是
还需要时间这不真的事实
而且后面的进程还很多
因为我们现在在讲AI都还是很皮毛
就是像確實你跟他對話
或問他個問題而已
未來要的是可以幫你解決問題
解決就是完成任務
就是所謂代理人AI
甚至未來要做成機器人自駕車
那個老實講還很遠
當然最主要關鍵點是
到底硬體會成長到哪裡
可是最基本的角度
我個人覺得確實我自己的看法
也認同台積電講
以現在的角度而言
兩三年之內是
我覺得要大幅反轉的機率真的很低
但是我常講
你就算不要講那麼遠
因為市場不斷會有變化
最基本來講看到二七年是沒有問題
代表現在的架構是
就算是年中出發都是很安全的
我常常回過頭來
我永遠講的就是
這兩年的這個必勝招只有一套
就是你就是資金靠攏AI
跟拉高持股比重就是你只要一直維持這兩個堅信不移其實你就跟著这个指数不断走高或者是我常常讲甚至我常常讲甚至盘面不要花那么多时间
你认真上班
在公司那边等于本业多赚点钱
那你投资这边不要花太多心力
这我自己的感受
因为我觉得这几年
因为涨的速度很快
我觉得投资人常常会有个问题
就是对本业越来越不重视
会觉得我今天随随便便就可以赚个两三千块了
我做了一整天
昨天八小时卖给老板都还没那么多
然后问题是
这个不代表是一个永远的常态
你必须要本业跟着你的投资同时成长
而且要记得就是投资是你终身的事情
工职场也是非常长期的事情
絕對不可能說未來完全就專業投資
我個人覺得這是難度非常非常高
因為我們 就算我們法人
我一直覺得能夠跳脫這個圈子
然後完全做專業投資完全不上班
老實講 就我以前角度我覺得
我遇到我都會覺得很敬佩
我不管你能夠賺多少錢
你可以 我們以前有那種10年
超過10年 20年最後都沒上班的
我也不知道說你到底賺多少錢
但是你可以一二十年不上班
就靠这股票赚钱
我就觉得很了不起
因为股票在投资里面
强的不是短时间赚很多
强的是能够长期一直在赚
我觉得这个才是厉害的
这个投资人
就我们的角度出发
所以我刚刚讲
本业真的要认真
然后不要本业跟这个投资的
次序搞混
那如果你说
所以我个人觉得要
应该现在是多投
所以你在投资的用心度要比以前认真
我觉得这是合理的
那你应该是你可以花你其他
这个所谓的空闲的时间
并不是花你本业的时间来认真
那你应该说这个花时间在这个上面
但是要有一定的限度
你一直要去追求最高的报酬
不见得是优势
其实我刚刚讲
你往AI靠拢真的不行
都买ETF
然后把持股拉高
然後中間不管誰說了什麼言論
你只要冷靜下來想一下
明年27年的AI的這個浪潮到底會不會因為川普講的這句話改變或者是比如說了什麼事情而改變不會的話你就不用緊張那後續維持高持股
那剛剛提到往AI靠攏
等到短時間是沒有感受的
但是你只要時間拉長
一季兩季之後你就會發現這個策略
其實能夠讓你每天生活
不會應該說你的心情
不會受到投資大幅震盪的影響
而且獲利層面會不斷地走高
因為剛剛明漢講到一件事
讓我想到我漏了一個事情
忘了要跟明漢分享
以及跟觀眾和聽眾朋友分享
大家都知道我會去東森對面
有一個地方改衣服
改衣服的老闆娘也是很神奇
上過好幾家大型的雜誌
因為她改衣服改到出名
我昨天去找她
就發現了兩件事情
第一件事情就是我變胖了
她幫我改衣服的時候
我會選以前這個牌子
S號的我還要再修
他昨天有幾件
我就覺得好像差不多
回去量體重真的變胖了
好 這第一個
第二個他就千交代
萬交代
我要感謝婉婷跟敏翰
因為這個老闆娘多厲害
他都有在做股票
所以後來我越去
他越喜歡跟我聊天
最近有一段時間沒有去
他做股票讓我有個印象很深刻
他去聽我們這些財經節目
所以他就知道現在在熱什麼
好 例如說最近熱被動元件
他可能就真的買一下國具或什麼
但他會遵守什麼呢
熱蒙古
跌破五日线我就先出厂一趟
那如果站上我就再买回来之类的
他就用这种很简单的
可是他都锁定我们讲的热门AI股
然后他就有讲到说
因为你知道缝缝补补补这个衣服
有时候手工活也很累
他就说他最近也有流失员工
就是有员工呢
就觉得股票有赚钱了
就说我才不要在这边缝衣服了
我就走了
可是老板娘他很热爱这件事情
他就继续当然继续做他的本业
本业做得很好
然后也有投资股票
那为什么他要感谢婉婷跟明翰呢
他最近拿到一張證照
台灣只有他一個人有
就是GOTEX的修補的證照
要全英文考試
那他呢說
你知道我看那一疊的時候
我本來就是要放棄
因為我根本就不懂什麼英文
可是我就看到明漢哥
他不能叫你哥差不多
他說他看到明漢
接受採訪的時候提到
以前國中是混不良少年
然後呢高中的時候
可能26個英文字母都還學不起
可是後來呢
卻因為自己苦讀不但英文超六
還用全英文考到CFA第三集
這個勵志的過程
他就告訴自己說我不能放棄我不能放棄全英文我也要克服全英文也要克服然後因為婉婷有一次來上節目也有提到他不是一個最聰明的人可是他是一個最努力的人
每天都為了做研究產業
熬夜到半夜然後哭啊什麼的
還是這樣熬過來
他說他就憑藉這兩個人的故事
就決定自己要克服這個全英文的認證考試
通過了
台灣就這麼一張
然後中國有一張
然後所以我就聽了就覺得很為他高興
所以他就特別來跟我們分享這個事情
我覺得他帶來很多的意義
就是你要相信你自己的行業行行出狀元
他不是AI產業
可是他的手工業還是非常的厲害
可以得到國際的認證
再來他不懂英文
可是他卻通過了一個全英文的考試
再來他也做股票
而且做得還不小
可是他的方法很簡單
熱門趨勢
加上一些很簡單的技術現行判斷
對
然後他又很相信我們達人講的
他就這樣又賺本業錢
又賺本業技術
又賺投資財
然後他跟我說一定要當面謝謝明漢這樣
對
應該這樣 我覺得這個真的是很勵志
我覺得這個真的很值得大家鼓勵
我常常講的就是
真的本業自己要拿捏一個喜歡的方向
認真不斷的往前進
因為投資真的是
我覺得雙面真的都要認真
你往一個方向靠攏
其實風險真的很高 尤其是投資
因為我常講投資會有一個
他会给你一个错觉
在这个多头的时候
你会觉得你是股神
但是这个不真的
当然我要
我这个讲这个时候
有时候有矛盾
我跟大家讲有风险
可是你又说不会
你刚刚不是讲未来又是好的
但是常常讲的时候
有时候你没有经过中间的犀利
或者说我们
或者举一个比较好的例子好了
就是说这接近三年的AI
之前关税的时候也是跌到半天
你当时你有沒有那个信念
能夠沒關係我不怕
我就覺得是AI是好的
你有沒有經過那個洗禮
絕大部分人當時是沒辦法
過度過內關的 對不對
所以你未來26年27年
你也不敢保證
未來會不會有這樣的一個架構
然後你永遠走在這鋼索邊緣
最後很容易就會有出狀況的時候
所以我很認同
真的就是要本業跟這個
所謂的投資雙面都要認真
我常常覺得
我覺得偏背的都很嚴重
比如說我遇到很多就是
投資很認真
最後本業也愛做不做的
就跟他讲
你这个看得出来你的投资已经没有问题
你应该多认真一点
你的本业比较实在
另外有遇到一些就是不太
可能不太投资的
我就会跟他讲
你不知道现在人家财富不断的在拉开
你不投资你会很辛苦
因为你只靠本业
你感觉你自己在赚
可是这个股市在往上的过程当中
大家的财富快速拉伸
其實你要記得一件事情就是
你這個100萬到底是多還少
這個取決於大家之間的財富的比較
你當所有台灣投資人
大家100萬是基礎的時候
其實你100萬 你只有100萬你是窮人
所以這個概念就是說
大家現在的獲利大幅走升的情況下
其實你如果你的這個獲利一直上不去
那其實就是一個代表你在一個退後
我常常覺得這個觀念是
必須要跟大家分享
所以我覺得
那個老闆娘的故事
真的是 也真的是蠻勵志的 我覺得
那當然 我也覺得
不過常常講這種
我自己都會覺得
我可能已經過那個年紀
但是我以前
確實就是
為了本業也很認真
那時候我覺得投資我還
一開始的時候
我還沒有花非常大的心力
我就是本業的部分
一定要想辦法先把自己先拉上去
那後來
當然這是我的運氣
因為我的本業本身就是投資
所以當我的本業
把自己的能力拉上去之後
代表我的投資
也真的越來越好
但是我另外要分享一件事情
就是再講到投資這件事情
我要跟大家講
我不只是剛剛提到的
本業就算你的基礎多低
你只要認真都會上得去
投資也一樣
我通常遇到投資人
他會再講到投資
一些分享的時候
他都會常常跟我講
欸 沒關係 你直接告訴我哪一檔就好
其實我聽不太懂
我 我 我
對 我的概念
我要講一個很重要很重要的觀念
我從 我這一輩子我看了這麼多人
我從來沒聽
我從來沒看過有一個人說
欸 他只聽誰誰誰講誰誰講的
然後最後能夠累積財富
發家支付
發家支付變成有錢
這個是絕對不可能的
任何人不管是主力什麼
他其實多少對這個公司
都有他一套方法方法每个人不同他一定有一套方法去了解他的结构或怎么样静更出你不可能永远有一个人带着你
带你一辈子
这是绝对不可能的事情
所以无论如何
投资也必须要理解
但还有一个很重要的事情
投资真的没有想象的难
回过头来
人家会告诉我说
这说你不能这样讲
因为你受过
比如说你教育训练各样的
刚好我在跟大家讲一个
我自己亲身的体验
我会觉得
我今天后来
我自己也觉得
我最后能够理解
抓出很多方法
我个人觉得我连运气好
我确实
我认真不是说
我的基础有多好
是我每一次错误
我会很快的去修正
我觉得这是我最大的优势
或结论来讲
我平常看到厉害的投资人
我发现跟背景一点关系都没有
或者我只是反向而言好了
我在投资圈20年了
所以我也预估了很多
平均可能在投资圈经历20年的人
我老实讲
真正对投资
我们在聊天之间
因为其实聊天之间
我讲几句话
我就知道你的逻辑跟你的能力在哪里
我个人觉得就我们投资圈
最后能够胜出
然后靠投资
能够轻松自在赚到钱的
我个人觉得那个比例
其实比你想象的低很多
很多 結論來講就是投資圈的人
大部分也跟一般人沒有太大差異
一般人裡面也存在非常很多
很強很強的投資人
我個人覺得就是那個比例
並沒有因為他讀財務
或者是受過什麼背景
或者在曾經在法人圈就特別厲害
我個人覺得那個比例是差不多
所以結論就是剛剛提到的
其實無論是本業跟投資
其實都需要花一點心力在上面
不要每天只想要
谁谁谁跟我讲得很准
其实这一套理论是不可能走长久
最后无论如何
都要找到自己的方法
要怎么去找到自己的方法去突破
那能够未来不靠任何人
你就能够持续的不断的增长财富
我觉得那个才是最重要
所以我刚刚提到
双面都要努力
但是结论都没有想象的难
不是那种一开始就说
我不行其实没有
我真的沒有想像的那麼難
就像我去找對面的老闆娘她也不是叫我報牌給她她是跟我講她買了什麼然後她還跟我講她怎麼買賣的我就想好像是聽老闆娘報牌給我
沒有開玩笑
因為她有在看我們節目
我覺得她就是一個自己吸收以後
歸納出一個很簡單的邏輯
對
那她在對等關稅的時候還有加碼
那她的加碼想法也非常簡單
她就說那我就加碼紅海好了
紅海應該沒問題
她的想法就這樣
疊這麼多了紅海
紅海本益比已經很低了
我就加碼紅海啦
欸 其實好像也沒錯
就跟你對等關稅你不想要買什麼
你買個指數
或是你買一個台積電
你可能不會太擔心
那他就個人可能比較喜歡紅海
就這樣子啊
我覺得還蠻有意思的一件事情
也跟各位聽眾或觀眾朋友分享
因為我也覺得是蠻勵志的
我每次聽到這種事情
你就會覺得
這個社會不是說
我們今天一定要身處在AI領域
才能夠賺錢
可是我們做的事情
我有一個好朋友
他有在修行這樣子
他就讲说我们现在在传递的事情
也算是一种说法
一种说法
因为我们想要教的是正确的观念
而且就是因为社会的现状如此
所以投资变成一个很重要的事情
但不是投机
一定要像明翰刚刚讲的
我们要如何长期的
在这样的一个社会现状里面
长期稳健的获利
是我们这个频道
觉得最重要的一件事情
所以最后我想请明翰讲一下
因为今天有很多的产业是
例如像被动物件
是一个团灭的状况
记忆体是一个团面的状况
因为美光组颜盘后大跌
你说我们什么很奇怪的事情
其实都不外乎就是那些
一下说你长太多了
大家没有办法附和
一下就说没有关系
就继续长会长到2028
就是不断地这样来回
如果现在
因为之前明翰教过我们分十次进场
然后你还在友台讲过什么543
对不对
所以现在的话
如果要选产业
你会觉得今天盘面上
或说最近这段时间
比较能够立即入手的
以及回后应该要减的
以及543到底是一个什么样的进场法
其实结论
到底我常常讲
我在涨的时候
讲了可能持有的人就不太高兴
我会讲其实
简单的概念就是
大家在四月之后因为指数大涨
所以它有个特色就是
最后涨得乱七八糟
什么都涨
就是簡單來講就是這個概念
昨天也有這種感覺
對 然後有一個特色就是我自己的觀念就是說你要能夠長期能夠賺到錢你把握你只要所有事情都不重要
你只要做一件事情做到
你就可以整個投資完全改變
一件事就是不要看圖說故事
就是不要因為他長了
你就覺得他很厲害
不要因為他跌了就很害怕
那其實害怕不害怕
你可以很簡單的去找一些證據
就可以理解
那我之前就講
記得一件事情就是
AI從已經三年了
然後有很多的族群
我們就不一一點名了
因為結論就是
今年四月才起漲
其實你就可以知道
為什麼前三年
功率元件
對 前三年都沒有
突然今年年初也沒有
第二季之後
突然說他吃到AI
非常非常厲害
那我就覺得很納悶
我就講白一點就是
你要記得就是從這個
當時應該說在AI有沒有大幅轉變的時候有
就像兩年前從Harper轉Blackwell
那時候你說突然誰切入供應鏈了我還信
然後下一代這個Vila Rubin
它要下半年才出來
所以照理講現在其實在四月之後到目前
其實基本面都沒有什麼改變
所以結論來講就是好的還是好
不好的也還是不好
那但是因為指數長太多
所以很多人就開始明顯的補上
那我常常講
有一個特色在漲的過程當中
只要相關族群一大漲
你就不用擔心
無論是這個新聞
或者是很多的分析師都會告訴你
他會幫你找到很多利多
告訴你說他這個有多厲害
因為他就是AI族群
那我常常講的就是說
這我們以前法人受的基本訓練
如果以前我寫報告長這樣
這一定被罵的
或者說之前如果
寫報告長這樣
對 就是你不能只講故事說
他是怎樣
你要個證據
找到相關的數字圖形給我看
但是問題是他所有的圖形畫出來
都是沒有東西的
現在有很多報告
已經想辦法就是編故事
哈哈哈哈
不得不講
對 但是我常講
或者直接提高評價啦
我覺得我們剛剛有
對 最後就是
我們
就是講故事講完提高評價
直接提高評價
或者是
或者是你說他也不是啊
我都有拉高EPS
但是问题是拉高EPS的部分
都是凭它的感觉来的
所以最后没有太大的意义
反正我常常讲
没关系你怎么讲那是你的事情
拿数字给我看营收有吗
没有吗
因为营收是无法作假的
你吹嘘说你有多厉害那是另外一回事
营收就是不真的事实
我常常讲你还记得一件事
他跟你讲有增长
你要有一八尺
上市贵企业整体的均值
到五月就成长三成
你如果三層以下的
我们应该好好检视这些说
现在都不增长
然后未来会有多厉害
那我常常讲三月不厉害
四月之后特别厉害
五月越来越厉害
我常跟大家讲
这个不是说错
这个是我只是要告诉大家
这不是代表这种族群不能买
可是你不要在买的过程当中
被市场的氛围嬉恼告诉你
其实这个是前两三年
這個時候常常人家會拿以前的故事說
兩年前大家去追逐那些台積電什麼
那個都已經長太多不要看
現在最厲害的星星來了
它未來會再複製當年500的台積電
到現在2500 長5倍
所以它現在還很便宜
這個時候一定要買
它未來AI會有多厲害
我常常講聽聽就好
因為它沒有數字
有數字就是有數字
沒數字就是沒數字
差別差在哪裡
中间过程再往上过程
你是看不出任何差别
可是当拉回的情况下
就会开始有差别
差在哪里
在拉回的过程当中
我个人觉得
以今天这个角度
远远不足
你如果就今天这个角度
最起码来三天
大家才有那个感受
今天大家只是
今天只是大家心情不好而已
代表什么
就是恐慌跟洗筹码还远的
你最少三天之後 大家開始恐慌
那時候不是說心情不好
那時候是大家急著要問診說
到底還行不行啊 怎樣 到底要不要砍啊
那個時候才代表開始洗手
那個時候我就跟你講 差別在
當那個時間點結束了
假設最後發現烏龍一場
然後指數指紋開始一反彈的時候
就會有一個現象
我們就算這一段時間
可能有五個強勢族群押回
在反彈之後
也許只剩下兩個或三個人過高一定会有人就再也就过高不了那很简单那到底这个时候就来了谁会过高不了很简单我刚刚提到你回去看一下
到五月的营收数字
你不代表没有
不代表营收不好的
就一定不会过高
我刚刚讲
就是说五个最后三个过高
这里面可能还是有一些没营收的
但是代表什么
现在市场氛围还在那个产业上
那我刚刚讲
这个就是在涨一个市场氛围
就是漲那個本益比往上拉的一個概念
他可能會講那是以後的事情
那問題是這個等到數字要進來
那個都用年來算
結果股價呢
光一兩個月就可以漲好幾倍
所以就是正在提前反應的一個過程
所以我常講
結論就是在我漲的時候
你不用管任何基本面
只要強勢你就買
但是特色像種族群
就是買紅不買黑
拉回不要买
一拉回 現在開始拉回了
就是我那時候講
買紅不買黑 拉回你現在不要
因為這些很多族群是沒有數字
你不知道下一次質問反彈過高會不會是他
你現在是沒有辦法缺
你現在問誰都不知道
所以就是之前在告訴你說
這個族群特別厲害那個
你今天問他可能也跟你講不用怕
因為才第一根
等到三天之後
如果這樣三天再中說你再問他
你覺得怎樣 他會跟你講
我覺得可能有點怪怪的
所以我在想说
这故事不太一样
所以就目前的角度
以今天其实很多
涨多的族群都在修正
摊开
我们直接讲
我觉得好的族群好了
就今天角度打到快跌停
甚至PCB CCL都打到快跌停
PCB今天回涨蛮深
星相电
对 你回去看一下
刚刚讲的这些个股
五月营收都在创历史新高
没有错 涨价升级题材
对 然后人家创历史新高
而且今年這個營收都是五成以上成長的
然後現在拉回你會怕
然後很多營收都不成長
拉回你還很勇敢買
因為這些族群是因為這幾個月很
市場的氛圍很強勢
所以你會很熱
但是PCB已經兩年了
所以它的熱度源不及
這兩個月轉強的族群 對吧
所以會有一個問題
你很容易被市場的氛圍帶著走
但回過頭來
那個數字啊
你只要網路一查
或你問個Google說
幫我把那個
Google 或者甚至你問AI
請他把這幾個月的營收調出來畫一個線形 他馬上就出來了然後他畫給看你再看一檔一檔照妖鏡你就知道真假所以結論我剛剛提到我們上次來拆營收的時候也告訴大家
這五月營收拆開
我肉眼看下去
當然每一次都是散的
可是裡面有兩大族群是很明顯的
一個就是PCP
一個是設備
設備股
這兩個創高的個股其實蠻多
這兩個族群其實今天跌蠻重
那我就想 如果你就分批的角度
你就要去找這個有營收的
這個有營收不代表說指數一穩
他們反彈力道就一定是最強 不
但是有個好處
你只要願意等他一定會再過高
因為他們的數字是不斷創高
所以代表好 你五月營收創高
六月就算沒創高 震盪之後七月創高
他股價就創高
可是現在有很多的 最近很強的
其實營收都還是躺平的
那現在就是拉本益比市場氛圍
只要市場氛圍突然一結束了
就代表這個族群就不會再過高
後續開出來數字都是平的
所以它代表他也沒那個能力過高
所以這常講我們前段就提到
這個四月後才轉強的族群
就把握原則
就是強勢的時候一定可以操作沒有問題
因為你就是跟著市場的氛圍做
那把握原則就是買紅不買黑
那如果我們剛剛提到
分批比如說把資金分成無筆拉回買
把握原則你要買之前
網路查一下
就是它的到目前為止營收是非常亮眼
而且你要知道
現在又即將來到這個月底了
所以代表過一段時間
又要再公佈6月營收了
然後如果這個營收一直出不來
又漲這麼多
然後線型又受到破壞
你也很難再去預期
大家要再去做拉抬的動作
我可以簡單的歸納
发现我已经是名汉达人
名汉喜欢有基本面的东西
然后呢
有基本面不断在创高的
虽然评价可能都比以前
我们认识的PCB或设备股高很多了
可是现在叫做
整体的台股受AI的影响
整体评价提升
我们要先有这个概念
所以为什么回档可以减
回档可以减的
一定是营收有创高的东西
PCB跟设备
就是名汉长期讲没有问题的
那设备呢
5月角出好营收是有意义的
我记得我们上礼拜有讨论过
因為通常他們喜歡在半年
6月或是12月
是一個比較密集的入帳的時間
就記底啦
那現在才5月就已經有人陸續入帳了嘛那6月的話想必應該會有更多的好成績這個是一個設想但是其實很多设备厂商在开法说的时候都告诉大家我的订单都已经到2028、2029、2030了
现在已经要看2030了
所以这些没有问题
PCB实在在营收
是那种所谓的三位数的年增率
这个没有问题
所以他们叫做回档可以减
那什么时候叫做买红不买黑
大家想说
哎呦还叫我买红不买黑
就是在讲
它的营收成长率没有那么强
可是族群性跟公式非常强的
被動元件
其實被動元件
他們的營收成長
或是獲利成長
沒有他們股價長得那麼多
所以他們是一個勢頭型的東西
勢頭型的東西就很看
這個勢頭能不能延續
當然有人說
今天跌停我去撿
搞不好明天會漲停
有可能
可是就不是明漢講的
它是一個勢頭要強的
你可能會撿得
有一點提心吊膽
公路元件我也在觀察
雖然最近真的超級強
可是公路元件
有沒有三級跳的營收
其實並沒有
目前并没有
不过功率元件确实也传出涨价
连成熟的制程
成熟的IT设计
连发科
对不对
都说有一些产品要涨价
所以确实有搭上最新一波的涨价题材
因此他们就成为盘面上的新宠
那新宠就要乘势
所以我就简单归纳一下
其实明汉哥的逻辑是非常非常非常一致的
最后我用一个问题
因为我最近有点少回答大家的问题
来做一个收尾
也讓明漢一起來回答
其實這個問題可以泛用在大家的身上
那這位朋友是因為他自己有買個股
就是買了翔碩
我們先不論翔碩是好還是不好
因為他自己有做了一些調查
就覺得目前的業績可能會不如預期
然後他就說
趙華那如果你今天發現手上的持股產業不如預期
你會怎麼樣
你會堅持等待嗎
因為他說後面會開花
那我就要一直左側一直撿一直撿嗎
還是我乾脆就應該把一半的資金挪去
主動是ETF
比較活潑會有表現的
那我看到這個問題的時候
我沒有辦法馬上用文字回答這位朋友
當然第一你會選擇買它
而且買到可能有壓力
代表你的資金部位可能有相當大比例
已經放在它身上
所以這是一個資金配置的問題
大家有沒有能力把大部位的資金
放在某一檔個股上面
而影響到自己情緒
我覺得這個是第一個你要了解的
然後第二個
當然現在的環境
它並沒有那麼適合左側交易
尤其是當你已經認為
他短期內可能業績不見得會有好的表現
而你的心智上已經有點無法承受了嘛
你確實就應該
〔此段辨識失敗，約 50:00 起〕